bueno
[Música]
a escala en parís ayuda palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y france 24
hoy dedicamos este espacio a hablar de
moda de diseño y corresponsable con una
mujer que está creando tendencia en
parís con prendas de alpaca hechas a
mano hoy recibimos a la franco peruana
cynthia guerrero cynthia muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros a los 10
años deja a perú y se instala con su
madre en francia y tras sus estudios y
el paso por una gran marca de lujo
decide lanzar la marca estela par de
prendas hechas a manos con la mano con
alpaca y corresponsable y no hizo
estudios de diseño los hizo de comercio
cuando decide lanzarse a esta aventura
de la moda
bueno pues cuando está en perú cuando
era niña mi madre y casi toda mi familia
trabajaba en textil
en ese famoso lugar que ahora está en
parís lo conocen que se llama gamarra
que es verdaderamente la
o sea es la parte donde se hace toda la
producción de alpaca pero también de
algodón
mayormente algodón de producción para
todo el continente latinoamericano y
norteamericano y eso creo que bueno
desde niña tuve las ganas de trabajar en
textil
cuando vine a francia me quedé con esa
idea y después de haber terminado mis
estudios entre una empresa un grupo de
lujo internacional francés y
directamente después de tres años de
experiencia decidí de enlazar más marca
pero en realidad era un proyecto que
tenía desde siempre que es para usted la
moda y la moda o el diseño de
corresponsable la moda para mí es sobre
todo un placer es algo es un placer pero
bien poderoso un poco como la comida es
algo que tú puedes hacerlo porque
simplemente es una necesidad pero puedes
volverlo algo importante y de una pasión
y algo que te va a cambiar tu día por
con la moda puedes tratar de ser más
feliz de sentirte más guapa y entonces
sentirte más poderosa y tener ganas de
tener un día increíble pero también
claro tiene una parte muy importante de
mensaje
y es para mí es la razón por la cual
escogido hacer una marca y
corresponsable entonces el mensaje que
yo quería transmitir es de que algo que
sea que es muy bonito que es simplemente
estético puede transmitirse en algo que
tiene valores éticos y humanos y de
responsabilidad ecológica también detrás
de eso cuando comienza tiene ha
informado mal a dos tejedoras sin en
lima si ahora mismo ya son 80 me
corregirá si no si no es cierto
porque decide emplear a mujeres en lima
y creo que solteras en un principio creo
k idea algo de historia de familiar o
personal
exactamente simplemente porque yo nací
en un país en el cual
bueno no hay muchos derechos o sea ahora
se está mejorando pero en ese entonces
no habían muchos derechos para las
madres solteras
a nivel judicial y mi madre a mí me
y bueno hizo de mí una mujer con ganas
de ser muy poderosa una guerrera total y
mi madre me inspiró y mi abuela bueno
desafortunadamente también tuvo esa es
historia en la cual cuido a diez niños
ella sola y bueno son mujeres que me han
inspirado toda mi vida y que simplemente
me han transmitido el mensaje de que no
es porque la vida te pone así no te da
la vida ideal en la que tú te imaginas
de crecer que finalmente no puedes hacer
eso de una fuerza y al final cuando tú
te vuelves madre te vuelves mucho más
fuerte y yo quería transmitir ese
mensaje a las mujeres ahí en perú y
decirle mire al final nosotros hemos
logrado hemos llegado en un país donde
no hablábamos al idioma casi no teníamos
contacto aparte mi tía y bueno nos hemos
integrado súper bien y nos ha ido súper
bien entonces todo se puede con un poco
de voluntad de trabajo de hecho en el
nombre de la marca no es por casualidad
no es el nombre de mi abuela correcta
cómo se hace el trabajo con las personas
que tejen en lima usted decide diseñar
ellas producen las va a visitar cómo se
hace yo hago todo el diseño aquí en
parís bueno porque simplemente vivo aquí
luego voy dos veces al año a perú donde
tenemos un taller de desarrollo en el
cual se desarrolla de manera muy
discreta por problemas de
confidencialidad no todas las nuevas
colecciones en este taller trabajo con
mis mejores tejedoras bueno qué son las
con las que comencé a elsa y silvia y
ahí también santiago porque bueno
trabajamos con mujeres pero también con
algunos hombres son muy pocos pero pero
hay algunos y esas personas se ocupan de
todo el desarrollo de las nuevas
colecciones y de verdad se trabaja de
manera
lo hacemos juntos no sea día tras día si
comienza con un switch para desarrollar
el punto y luego se va avanzando y de
dónde sale la albahaca porque en el
corresponsable está el tema de pagar
bien a las tejedoras supongo pero
también mirar un poco el producto no la
trazabilidad que eso es lo que
diferenciaría a una marca de
corresponsable no si de otras que no
claro se preocupan por por esa
trazabilidad por ese camino que hace
bueno en perú sales tenemos la suerte de
bueno primero es el mayor productor de
alpaca del mundo hace 85% de la
producción de alpaca se hace en perú y
ya tenemos la suerte de tener empresas
que verdaderamente han evolucionado en
ese sentido no de querer ser más seco
responsable son empresas grandes que
ahora tienen que tienen sus las del ser
internacionales como the cost cal
y bueno obviamente nosotros
seleccionamos esas empresas para
trabajar nuestras nuestras colecciones
pero también trabajamos con empresas más
chiquitas con artesanos que ellos hacen
su propia alpaca o que hacen por ejemplo
su propio algodón también porque sabes
que en perú tenemos una gran variedad de
algodón pima pero también el tangüis que
es un algodón más ecológico porque
consumen menos menos agua y trabajamos
con estas empresas que no tienen acceso
a los claveles internacionales porque
simplemente es muy costoso y son
artesanos pero en realidad tienen el
producto el más seco responsable que tú
puedes hacer porque lo hacen todo a mano
de manera casi familiar
recortan todo el algodón a mano los
genios hacen a manos con plantas
utilizan porque yo misma voy a verificar
cómo se hace todo este proceso utilizan
maderas que ya no utilizan que
encuentran en la calle o de muebles que
ya no se que se están cayendo y hacen
algunas cajas en las cuales van a
utilizar van a poner los teñidos con
plantas para hacer todos los tejidos
artesanales justamente
a veces uno piensa en esos tintes la
industria de la moda durante mucho
tiempo ha dado la espalda a la ecología
y tintes o químicos que son realmente
muy nocivos
es difícil hacer moda y corresponsable
aún no se da cuenta de que finalmente si
se tienen las herramientas mira es
difícil pero siempre hemos tenido las
herramientas si tú ves a los tejidos de
la civilización nazca por ejemplo que
hasta ahora se guarda que hasta ahora
los tienes hay museos en parís que son
preciosos todo está hecho con plantas y
siguen intactos entonces uno puede pero
es mucho más costoso y toma mucho más
tiempo lo que las empresas no quieren
hacer porque bueno por por cuestiones de
costo y también porque obviamente es
menos rentable es de hacer algo que todo
toma tres días para en vez de hacer una
simple teñido que te toma mucho más
entretenido mucho menos
justamente vestir eco-responsables no es
barato o sea hacer un jersey a mano que
te puede costar hasta 45 días se puede
vestir de forma de corresponsables y
mucho dinero o realmente es para
la gente con un poco de dinero mira la
verdad ahí hay un dilema no la verdad es
que obviamente tú siempre vas a pagar
más por un producto de mejor calidad es
normal y nosotros a esto lo apartó
tratamos de tener el para mí el el
comercio justo es un precio justo para
el que produce pero también es un precio
justo para el que consume entonces
tratamos de desarrollar prendas que sean
corresponsables con un precio más
accesible porque no quiero no quiero que
sea algo que simplemente toque a una
parte de la sociedad o exclusivo no es
cierto pero es difícil de tener una
prenda un por ejemplo un jersey que te
va a costar menos de 190 euros si es que
no ese corresponsable ahí hay un
problema la gente tiene que simplemente
pensar que no es posible de tener una
un pueblo en algodón que te cueste 15
euros o 10 euros porque a veces veo
green fashion no sé que si en los la ves
y te ponen algo a diez euros no puedes
tener un polo a diez euros y dad calle y
trampa no creo que también hay trampa no
estamos sino también en la trampa o sea
uno también cierra los ojos pienso
porque la verdad tú sí tú piensas si un
polo cuesta diez euros como pasa y qué
está hecho no sé en bangladesh uno como
pasa el transporte que es carísimo desde
bangladesh extraer las prendas como
pagas la producción y como pagas la
persona que ya lo ha producido y claro
la y la persona que lo ha diseñado ya es
lógico el futuro de la moda
pasa por la de corresponsabilidad espero
que sí pero creo que sí porque la verdad
no quiero ser un idealista pero si lo
soy no puede impedirme y pienso pero
pienso de verdad que la gente está
tratando de consumir mejor claro no es
nada fácil para mí mismo es algo que es
complicado día a día no pero de verdad
veo uno en cambio en al menos por
ejemplo en nuestro instagram veo y no es
así los clientes que nos compran que
sean nueva york con tokio en francia los
las tiendas esas grandes que nos compran
pues yo veo una diferencia antes
comprado este la pardo simplemente por
el diseño es lo único que les interesaba
cuando yo les contaba la historia de mis
tejedoras de que está hecha a mano que
escogía simplemente 100 baby alpaca y
desea explicar la diferencia entre baby
alpaca y alpaca no les importaba y
explica nos gusta mejores y bueno le
pegué alpaca es la mejor fibra de la
alpaca baby alpaca la gente se confunde
a veces pienso que es el bebé alpaca
puede ser porque es la primera a ver en
español el atún del animal
y es su primera vez pero también puede
ser la mejor la mejor parte de la alpaca
es decir que tú en una tonelada de
alpaca vas a agarrar tu alpaca vas a vas
a hacer tu selección de la mejor fibra y
esa mejor fibra digamos que va a ser
sólo un 15% devesa tonelada y esa es la
baby alpaca en la fibra mala más larga
la más resistente y la más fina es muy
brevemente se sobreviva la pandemia la
moda puede sobrevivir a 66 mira yo
pienso que con trabajo y todo todo pasa
hay que simplemente ser paciente
y pensar en el futuro y nada más el
tiempo que pase muy bien pues muchísimas
gracias
guerrero por haber estado con nosotros y
muchas gracias a todos ustedes por
habernos acompañado ya saben que nos
pueden seguir por internet en rf y
mundo.com y en france24 punto com hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]